let's bring in joe koncha fox news
contributor and media opinion columnist
for the hill
joe good morning good morning happy
friday
yay thank goodness uh and we are
massless although we're in new york so
that we still have to wear a mask
because the governor has not said
we're going to drop the mass mandate joe
what happened
why did the administration out of
nowhere seemingly yesterday say you know
what
happy days are here again take off the
mask if you've been vaccinated
you look at the metrics right and i went
back and i watched an interview that dr
fauci just did a couple of days ago on
cnn
and he said that restrictions shouldn't
be lifted until the u.s
is below 10 000 cases per day
the seven day rolling average as of
yesterday is about 36 000
new cases per day so if we're having
more than three times the cases and
we're not at what dr fauci he only runs
the coronavirus task force
in terms of his own metrics then why was
this done as you said a very good
question and you wonder about the
political aspect of this when you
consider
the gas lines in south carolina and
georgia
and virginia and north carolina where a
majority of gas stations are closed
outright when you see
cyber infrastructure and that pipeline
that supplies all of those
gas stations suddenly get hacked and
then perhaps a ransom it looks like
reports say
was paid in order to turn it back on
when you consider the middle east is on
fire at least in israel
in gaza when you consider the border
catastrophe where we had a record
number of migrants encountered in april
the highest number in 20 years
and when you look at inflation and the
impact that that's having on every
american
you wonder about a old saying around a
dog and a wagon a tail at this point
media in full meltdown when this
announcement was made yesterday joe here
are some of the doctors on other
networks and what they had to say about
it listen
frankly i was shocked by this
announcement i think they went from one
extreme to
another and the major step that's
missing here is
how do we know that people are telling
the truth this is not a free-for-all
that everybody you know and but i agree
with dr when
it is going to be very tenuous i am kind
of befuddled as to where this guidance
came from
i think there are a lot of steps that
were missing and the people who
never wanted a vaccine how how do i
get them to wear a mask that is a great
question
i mean joe half the country's already
doing this if you have been vaccinated
why shouldn't we be able to take off the
mask this announcement should have come
a long time ago
absolutely ainsley and look fear is the
greatest motivator
is the old saying and maybe fear is also
the greatest motivator in terms of
reasons to watch tv or reasons to click
on a certain sort of online publication
for example
that talks about covet and tries to fear
monger people and that was dr liana wen
that you saw there on cnn
she also said this which i found very
interesting quote what's to stop
the unvaccinated from endangering
everyone
all right here's some stats for you as
recently as a week ago nearly 85 percent
of seniors in this country
have been vaccinated 95 of cover deaths
in this country occurred with people 50
and older this is all according to the
cdc and that's obviously because
of chronic conditions or because you
have an aging immune system so when she
says oh my god the unvaccinated are
going to kill everyone well the numbers
say that that simply
is not the case and you don't need the
numbers joe by the way to back up common
sense which says
if you get vaccinated if i am vaccinated
why do i need to worry about you
why do i care what you're doing if i'm
vaccinated that's the point
of the vaccine i can't believe those
people have a d and r before
before their name here's what i want to
get to with you joe here's why it's
important to question whether or not
science is guiding our decision making
because these same agencies will
continue to give us guidance
specifically when it comes to who needs
to be vaccinated
children for example they'll continue to
give us guidance that we
shall not question and harangue us if we
ask questions about it
and now we are looking in retrospect at
the guidance over masks and going
wait what was guiding you there if not
science
i'm glad you brought up children will
because you and i both have them mine
are young they're five and seven
and i just heard the cdc director not
five months ago not last year last week
talking about how a two-year-old might
have to wear a mask
if they go to a summer camp outdoors and
everybody outdoors at that camp
whether they're vaccinated or not
whether they're under five years old or
not
has to wear a mask so we went from that
to now hey if you're vaccinated
everything's okay but i still have
questions
i want to know if my seven-year-old girl
has to wear a mask at school still
if all the teachers are vaccinated why
does she have to do that
it's completely unfair it's starting to
get a little warm around here so it's
going to get uncomfortable as well
so more questions than answers right now
and dr fauci who never met a microphone
he didn't like
needs to start doing some interviews
today and people need to start
challenging dr fauci not be so afraid to
do it
and ask just basic questions that inform
americans and particularly parents
on what happens next yeah joe i did i
did do some research on that
because if you have a five-year-old
obviously she can't get vaccinated so
she will probably still have to wear a
mask at school if the school requires it
but they say they will update guidance
for schools and summer camps
looking forward to that ainsley no
question about it but in here in new
jersey
you go into any business i was in
several yesterday it was aaron's day
and i'm telling you not one person
wasn't wearing a mask and not one
business was like okay it's okay now
i have a feeling it's gonna take a while
for people to get out of this habit i
know where you were you were at market
basket and you were buying a turkey
yesterday
uh we should point out that that's
correct i know
i know wait sorry to interrupt you but i
heard again the groceries i heard
i heard in new jersey you all have a
place where you have a home goods at
maxx and a marshalls and a target in one
spot
but we probably have a couple of those
in one spot that's like a dream for any
woman
honestly if you're pretentious it's
marshalls and it's targeted
that's right that's right anyway joe i
was going to point out the fact that
your wife
is an emergency room doctor so you are
looking at the science as well
and you mentioned dr fauci dr fauci says
that as of yesterday he said come fall
schools will be wide open everybody back
five days a week
so what you know and for him to make
that change on the same day they made
the mass mandate change
you've got to figure the white house has
been doing internal polling
and the number one thing the president
had been doing best on was coronavirus
and i think people had probably had it
up to here
and the polling was going south and they
said you know what we got to pull the
plug on this we got to
we got to you know steer the ship this
way instead
so we went from follow the data follow
the signs listen to the doctors to
listen to the pollsters oh that's very
interesting because
they've been so accurate particularly
last year right yeah probably not a good
idea and by the way the president united
states
again uh was completely misleading in
his statement yesterday when he said
that nobody thought that we'd have this
many people vaccinated by now they
thought we'd
get to this number by the fall no
there's not one person in this country
that didn't think we'd get to the
numbers that we're at
here in mid-may given the trajectory
that we're already at when mr biden took
office so again
he keeps moving the goal post and no one
bothers to fact check or even challenge
him on these things in any way shape or
form then again it's very hard to
challenge somebody who rarely takes
questions or lowering the bar and keep
clearing it
and patting himself on the back good
point
all right joe concha with media review
and uh a review
of retail establishments throughout
northern joe our new pillows on the sofa
came from that shopping center
we appreciate new jersey thank you all
right joe thank you i want to go and buy
a jaguar now but apparently i have to
call the jaguar if i want to keep the
pretentious thing going so
hello to jaguars thanks joe you're good
we're just regular folks on this curvy
couch
you can call it jaguar okay thank you
appreciate that
bye